let's say that the relationship's going
wrong and it's something you don't want
to go wrong and you get very emotional
as this person says look I'm sorry but I
think this is the end of the line um and
your emotions go and you say what's the
plan and you think well there isn't a
plan because it is the end of the line
well there is a plan the plan is to say
for example it may not resonate with
everyone this happens to lots of people
we do get over it yes we could even be
emotionally scarred but Life Will Go On
nearly everybody finds somebody else if
that's what you want yeah and life will
continue if you have that in your head
and say it will take around 3 months on
average you'll go through a lot of
emotions but you will come out the other
side so take a deep breath you've got
three months of a rot and Tumble coming
for someone to have that as the plan Y
is a good plan because you're saying I'm
accepting it's got to I've got to go
through
it